welcome to this video playing field
master here from the UK at least it's a
flag from the UK ma choir so you have a
name in there no it's only playing five
minute ok yeah we are we got a fille du
Amador defense and this is one one line
that I even have studied myself a couple
of years ago it's a it's quite playable
for black funny enough this type of
position is a very very reminiscent of
the of the night off with this see point
exchanged against the deep on ah how is
this played
actually I think white takes with the
bishop assists did I confuse the move
order maybe okay well this is also
possible i'm not mistaken with Bishop e3
coming as a possibility okay so then I
approached attic and go here it's I must
try to keep control of course over d5
hmm what's this Bishop hmm take well
this should be three it looks attractive
it would be nice to get this exchanged
exchange this Bishop against the night I
mean I take take it take p7 and play see
form you know he's going to go a 6b five
my knight on f3 s is not very well
placed for the structure
but it's not easy to remove it okay
let's do this go for this transposition
on he probably needs to spend a move to
comedy 6 I know 2658 is quite
embarrassing okay at least that
something it's really the case young
look the look the air now it's trapped
ok so be five okay but after be five I
can actually take and take the six so
maybe I can okay if 4s attacked I need a
good strengthening move here you cannot
go maybe this one with the idea to play
rock d tool okay b5 takes takes a five
is is a possibility the knight on c3
would be excellent of course but not so
easy to to manage
does not really a does not really help
much okay this is useful anyway on b5 I
want to take play a five and I wasn't
sure how to set up the pieces
accordingly one minute 30 knots around
someone really quick in this game okay
tonight's 292 to see 5 warning some
yeah tricky position with 50 something
seconds on the clock
I don't think it's actually quite okay
for me but 50 seconds got the a pawn and
d5 is hanging if you place d4 i have
night c4 and it takes process yeah that
he can do that but I Bishop Bishop f2 we
can play to happen so he's got a good
tactics working fine we can take f2 ok
and didn't see that Queen takes 90 form
that's very good for me the book is
hanging and 9 f 6
ok
I be sure before
yeah that's not it's not easy 30 seconds
it's not easy to play unfortunately now
Derek and 10 what is shame check check
now Queen a force just a made-up check
check now unbelievable game chiming that
is probably winning for black check
amazing when what kind of nonsense black
can play and still win check check like
this it's the winning it's still really
a could couldn't we had made into when
the all kinds of stuff I mean what what
was the easiest I don't know there was
that wasn't made into somewhere which
was very easy yaquina for us g3 quenelle
to mate just one of the mates ah very
tricky position I mean okay I didn't
didn't really I couldn't really work it
out despite the the time that I used
yeah here you could have taken on f2 of
course yeah i'm not i'm not very well
coordinated now and here I'm winning
this exchange but it's a I can take on
b3 hem and I'm winning this exchange but
it is very tricky to play with the
Seaport very tricky to play gym
computer wants to go route da one and
sets wide windsor i'm not sure i'm not
really i'm not sure it's very difficult
for a human to play this it's just
easier for black to play with the
seaport the IT i had the made with Jack
somewhat didn't see even that is so
completely winning he blundered f7 but
it's check okay here that Jesse draw
actually check with Queen f5 quit effort
being a draw we're four seconds even
that was a job check and here why does
even winning with Queen edge form check
at the end yeah it's um ok this is the
add the problem when you when you place
so slowly in the opening it costs you
add at the end ok thanks for watching